the next award is for the Best Original  Score for a motion picture not a musical  in other words the music that makes the  joke sound funnier and the terror more  terrifying and now here to present this  award is our stocking president of the  Academy Gregory Peck  Thank You Roz with that kind of help I  could end up playing the lead and the  boys in the band  nominations for Best Original Score for  a motion picture not a musical are the  Fox Lalo Schifrin the lion in winter  John Berry Planet of the Apes Jerry  Goldsmith the shoes of the fisherman  Alex North Thomas Crown Affair Michelle  degrom Roz and the winner is John Barry  the lion in winter  mr. John Barry unfortunately could not  be with us tonight I'll accept it for  him with his gratitude and appreciation  thank you